but I've got my pack waiting to comment
on that sort of con interview but also
to talk about my next guest because the
2024 presidential race so far it was
like to be a rerun potentially of Donald
Trump against Joe Biden but this weekend
the grand smaller commentators claimed
that Trump could yet be disqualified
from the ballot altogether over his
alleged attempts to inspire Insurrection
my next guest may have some pretty
strong feelings about that Vivek
ramaswamy is the breakout star of the
Republican race so far the only one
frankly to rival Trump for any kind of
publicity or momentum there's just one
problem it doesn't really explained yet
how he'll actually beat Trump or Vivek
joins me now great to see you again
it's good to see you pierce how are you
well first of all an apology because
I've always called you Vivek and then
you very kindly corrected us all and
said you are Vivek as in cake
that's correct I appreciate best efforts
but uh I usually save the air time for
substance but thank you I appreciate it
we've done a few interviews viveka so
far and obviously when it started not
many people knew much about you other
than your entrepreneurial stuff now
since the last debate uh you've become
incredibly well known very well talked
about and a lot of uh unfriendly fire is
coming your way so my first question is
how are you handling being now in the
proper Spotlight of being a presidential
candidate
I'm fine with it and I do think Pierce
that's part of the process we jumped
into this race early on going in Eyes
Wide Open knowing that politics is a
dirty sport it's filled with falsehoods
you may have seen a report over the
weekend that actually one of the other
candidates large super Pacs was taking
credit to their donors for the donors
for the attacks that have been
manufactured against me that's okay I
can handle it and to tell you the truth
if I'm asking the people of this country
to ask me to represent the U.S across
the table from Xi Jinping I better be
able to sit across the table from other
candidates or from left-wing Media or
anybody else and so we're doing just
fine with it I'm focused on what we want
to achieve for this country shutting
down the administrative State keeping us
out of World War III declaring
independence from China growing the
economy Reviving national pride these
are my actual Focus areas not some side
attacks that could I really could care
less for okay you
seen so far I would argue the most
pro-trump of the other candidates but
that raises the question if he's so
great even to the extent you were pardon
him of any crimes you make him be
convicted of why would you run against
it why not just let Donald Trump run
again and potentially win again and
maybe you get a a good job out of it
otherwise if you keep talking him up how
does that help you
so the answer is I'm not looking at
what's going to help myself or not I'm
looking at speaking the truth and I do
think he was an excellent president as
judged by results but I'm going to
deliver something that he did not
National Unity uniting this country is a
top objective for me I'm 38 years old I
am the youngest person ever to run for
U.S president as a Republican and peers
we're reaching the Next Generation in
droves we're Reviving national pride
amongst Young Americans 40 percent of my
hundred thousand plus donors are first
time ever donors to the Republican party
in any form that is unheard of that
number is normally two percent and so
yes I'm 90 of policy areas I do agree
with Donald Trump and I respect his
accomplishments but there's more to a
president than just being a policy book
in a binder part of this is how we
reunite this nation I think I'll be best
positioned to accomplish that and I look
forward to working with Donald Trump
when I hope he's my advisor frankly my
mentor in my first year in office that
much I will take but that's how I think
this is going to play out you managed to
say that you thought Donald Trump would
be your advisor as president with a
straight face there Vivek
I do I think he's somebody who has a lot
of experience I don't want to start with
a standing start I want to build on
those four years of experience
that's just to explain on the agenda to
the next level no no I can see why you
would want him as an advisor since the
idea of trump playing second fiddle to
anyone I think he's highly unlikely uh
and I guess my overriding view is how do
you beat him he's so far ahead you know
you had a good debate I thought in many
ways you've got a lot of publicity out
of it but it hasn't really moved the
needle on the polls Trump is so far
ahead he looks Unstoppable and all these
indictments all they seem to be doing is
helping him
well I'll tell you one thing I I'm dead
set against these indictments that is
not how I want to win this election
seeing the cop opposition eliminated no
that's the wrong way to do it in this
country I will say this though Pierce I
started people said you started at zero
percent in March I said nope I started
at 0.0 in March I'm now a solid second
or third in nearly every major national
poll that's coming out and many people
in this country didn't even know who I
was six months ago most people couldn't
pronounce my name until two weeks ago
and so the fact of the matter is we're
on our way up I'm still introducing
myself to the country and I'm confident
that we're going to be successful
talking to you let me ask you this from
a farm in New Hampshire we're meeting
voters and I think we're very confident
about where we're at you are going to
have to take the gloves off with Trump
at some stage maybe on a debate stage so
what what don't you like about Donald
Trump
well look it's less about what I don't
like about him but what I do think this
country needs to go further I will unite
this country and if Trump was going to
do that in his four years that would
have already happened he delivered great
results but I think we have to actually
speak about this country in a way that
reaches the Next Generation talk about
what it means to be an American these
two devices I'm not in this race to run
against anybody but I am unique
ways to be unified you and I think
that's I know I know that's the essence
of what's differences
you are in a race and you are going to
have to try and beat Donald Trump and
it's interesting
the dividing point of view is these two
divisive right
well I think I am more unifying that's
the answer and I think that that's more
important and the way we're going to
unite this country is not by tearing
down other people who have made great
contributions to this country Donald
Trump being high on that list among them
but by actually articulating what this
country stands for answer what it means
to be an American at a moment where
we're in the middle of a national
identity crisis fill that void in the
heart of the millennial generation and
younger with an actual vision of
national identity instead of woke poison
or any other poison that fills that void
that's how we win
something for a long time we gotta run
start running two something that's what
I'm doing there's a little stuff about
you I really like you know hey you come
on my show a lot which I love and you
you do a lot of interviews and you're up
front and you take the tough questions
you go in lots of places where you might
get a hard time I love the energy I love
the dynamism really us but there are
aspects of some of your policy stuff
which I really don't like one of which
is your position on Ukraine and I want
to you this is a tweet that you did on
the day the war started
Putin is a bully the way to stop a bully
is to punch him in the nose you said now
now your position is you should just
give unless I'm wrong you should Ukraine
should just give Putin the land he's
stolen with his illegal War I don't know
how you equate those two statements
so Pierce I think there's two things
here one is we should have never been in
this situation in the first place
because if the U.S actually had energy
Independence if we drilled we fracked we
were a net exporter of energy Putin
would have never had the leverage to go
after Ukraine but now being where we are
it is our job to make sure that we
secure peace and Advance American
interests without sleepwalking into
World War III that is what I'm leading
us to do the answer is how have you
moved from a guy who illegally invades a
country a democratic sovereign country
you said the only way to stop this bully
Putin is to punch him in the nose but
when Ukraine in my view valiantly fight
for their territory and their people and
Putin still takes a load of their land
your answer to the bully is to now give
him what he's taken illegally
no that's not correct actually it's
going to be to require a major
concession from that bully so that we
don't ratchet this up to the next level
no no Peter Spears I think you're either
I mean and it's not your job to know
every aspect of everything I've said if
you're questioning on me on it I would
ask you to know what I've said countless
times I would actually require Putin to
exit his military alliance with China
that is the big demand and requirement
we will have for any deal of any kind
that russia-china military Alliance is
the single greatest threat to the west
and to the United States as we know it
Putin is in XI jinping's arms communist
China is fundamentally hostile to the
United States and I have a Clear Vision
for how to pull Russia apart from China
we will end the Ukraine war on terms
that leave Ukraine's sovereignty intact
I will note peers I'm skeptical that
that's even the path that Ukraine is on
right now so that's a win for Ukraine
but more importantly it's a winner it's
not a win for you crazy you know what if
you were president of the United States
yeah but giving a bully what he's taken
illegally is not to me strong leadership
is it
well Pierce I'm not giving anybody what
he's taken the fact of the matter is we
have to honor our covenants we had a
commitment to Ukraine in 1994 we've
fulfilled that commitment but James
Baker also made a commitment to
Gorbachev in 1990 on behalf of the U.S
saying that NATO would expand not one
inch past East Germany turns out NATO
has expanded far more after the fall of
the USSR than when the USSR activities
we should be clear okay NATO should not
admit Ukraine to Nato okay but I want to
be really clear about this beers I'm not
letting Putin has his actions are Craven
I've said so but I don't trust Putin I
do trust him to follow his self-interest
that causes him to exit we will I mean
many autocrats around the world or
bullies Putin is one of them but the
fact of the matter is you have to
actually do a deal that advances
everybody's self-interest okay require
Russia to exit its partnership with
China okay that's the key to the kingdom
to secure peace and keep us out of World
War III in fact we've run out of time on
this interview but I you know I'd love
to do with it I I feel like I've
interviewed you a lot but for you know
five to ten minutes at a time I don't
think as you get better and better known
people want to know more about you as a
human being I would love to get the
chance to sit down with you and have a
proper one-on-one about who you are
where you've come from because I think
you are igniting this whole presidential
race in an exciting way I don't agree
with you about some of the stuff you're
saying not least Ukraine but I do love
the way that you're out there doing your
thing and I would love to get a chance
to get to know you better
I enjoy our exchanges it would be
bizarre if we agreed on everything right
so let's do that join us on the campaign
Trail I'm talking to you from our
campaign bus ride the bus with us we'll
spend a day together I'd enjoy that and
you can also see how some of the
audiences here in the US are responding
yeah I think it's it's really motivating
to me but it's it's quite something to
see so final question before I'll let
you go and I want a quick answer if you
were president of the United States and
you might be in a year or so time what's
the first thing you would do what's your
number one priority
Implement a 75 head count reduction in
the federal bureaucrat base and shut
down government agencies that should not
exist that's how you revive the
lifeblood of a constitutional republic
it's also how you grow the economy
that's what I'll start on on day one
you're a fascinating guy and your race
is exciting people good and bad and ugly
but that's the way it often is I look
forward to meeting with you properly
face to face and having a more in-depth
chat thank you very much
thank you peers I look forward to that